also ich bin nicht durch kanzlerin ich
bin ja nicht das ganze beim bahnbauer
unterwegs und sie geht genau dort wo sie
alles ja als berg mensch hin game will
in die einsamkeit sie wird nicht mit
vielen menschen warnt sie willst dass
sich allein der verkauf steigen
ja es ist auch nicht gern wenn jemand
hinter oder vor ihr geht und sie geht in
ihrer schritt wie es ihre kondition
erlaubt sagt er wenig zeit zum
trainieren in die berge und wenn sie
vorschläge machen sollte dass man die
berge anders aussucht alles eben mit
diesem extrem konzentrierten ski fahren
dann ist sie die richtige ist aber dass
ich jetzt natürlich eine negative stimme
gegen das skifahren ausspricht ist
nachvollziehbar weil sie natürlich das
im kopf hat was in ist im winter
passiert ist aber eine frage noch wenn
die kanzlerin sie jetzt anrief und sagen
würden mensch der sebastian kurz will
unbedingt auf machen der sänger will
schließen was soll ich denn machen was
es richtig was würden sie sagen
da würde ich sagen da gab es doch den
versuchen sie die beiden einigermaßen
wieder in frieden miteinander reden zu
lassen